[Music]
tom's with us in lima ohio hi tom
welcome to the ramsay show
hey guys it's really nice to speak to
both of you you too what's up
hey i was wondering a little dispute
between my fiance and i yes
that's what we're here for
yeah we're getting married in 16 days
i'm 20 she's 21.
you lose whatever the dispute is you
lose
uh it's not much uh just a very slight
uh
disagreement i guess okay um that's how
i can tell you're not married there is
no slight disagreement but go ahead no
all right yeah
um to wait tiles in person whenever we
come down during our honeymoon but i
found a truck sooner than later
we're closing on selling our house we're
moving to
we're going to rent my grandparents
family farm with the plans of buying it
in three to five years
but anyways we have about a hundred and
two thousand in equity
on our house
that we'll be getting a check for
tomorrow
and then
we're wanting to
get a little bit nicer truck than we
have now what do you have now
i have a 2002 chevy with 170 000 miles
okay pretty rough and what do you make a
year
um between the two of us it's going to
be around 85 to 90. okay and what are
you talking about spending on a truck
i found a really nice 2017 f-350 for 37
000. so it'd be around 40 000 after
taxing title
nope
she wins
all right
is that just due to the income
yeah you're going to spend half your
income on a truck
okay you don't want to have more than
half here and you don't want to have
more than half your income tied up in
things that are going down in value and
by the time we buy her a car you've got
more than half your annual income tied
up and things going down in value you do
need a better truck but you went whole
hog here you need to back off a notch or
three
yeah like 10 grand okay
10 grand is 10 times nicer than what you
got
10 grand is 10 times nicer than what you
got
yeah
he doesn't sound enthused sorry man
listen no that's not really the answer i
was hoping for you called a couple of
dudes on a radio show and you're like
these guys will be we just ruined i'm
sorry yeah
hey you got a lot going on
you sold a house you're getting married
and you're moving all in less than a
month
it's okay if you wait to buy a truck a
little bit
yeah
okay yeah and and i i
you know
you have you have too many things too
many balls in there you're gonna drop
one and that was one you were getting
ready to drop you i i wouldn't do it i
wouldn't do it and you asked us and
because i want you to have a i want you
to be able to pay cash for this farm
more than i want you to have that truck
yeah i'd love to be able to put at least
30 or 40 percent down on the farm yeah
and the cheaper truck you buy the more
likely that is and the funnest part
about having a farm is all the gear
right
like i can't just have an f-150 or an
f-250 you have to have an f3 right it
just it just you can gear yourself out
of a lot of money man
no stop it john
yeah i know i like the toys man but no
no
no it's uh
here's the thing
things that have motors and have wheels
whatever they are they go down in value
like 99 of them do
and if you're going to build wealth you
minimize the things that you buy that go
down in value you maximize the things
that you bound to go up in value
fairly simple equation
but if you you know like
here's another one tom and john will
relate to this i was driving the other
day i cut through a back way and i got
over into this uh new little
neighborhood
and it was a little um it was nice
nice homes but they were starter home
maybe one half notch above a starter
home okay kind of slammed all together
and you know the little driveways are
coming down the front they're all kind
of it looks like a um truman show or
something right they they ran through
and just buzzed the trees down and just
threw them out yeah it's just a just
it's a subdivision you know kind of
classic right but nice they were nice
and they were it wasn't trashy
but they weren't mansions they weren't
even mcmansions okay
and but what struck me was
as i drove along there that most of the
cars were not in the garages they were
in the driveways in front of the garage
or in the street in front of the house
because they wouldn't fit in there
and as i'm driving along there i can
look and i'm adding up the price of the
two cars sitting in front of that house
and i go dude
if you weren't driving those two you
wouldn't be in that house yep
dude if you weren't driving those two
you wouldn't be in that house
and so you can tell these people have
got their thing bass backwards that's
right that's right and they've got all
their money in wheels
rather than in real estate they've got
their money in image right yeah well
yeah i mean because the people at the
stoplight need to be impressed exactly
you will never meet them but they need
to be impressed with the people that
walk by the parking lot where your car's
parked for eight hours of its day yeah
and they're really going to be moved by
that car you've got you know i mean i i
you know i uh
the first time i heard this really
pissed me off i had i was making good
money it was a real estate business
before i went broke and i bought a
jaguar
and i thought man i'm like i'm so bad i
got a jaguar i'm the coolest dude on the
planet
and my grandpa who worked 38 years as a
cost accountant at alcoa i went down to
see him now he had a um a 68
i wish i had this truck
68 short bed chevy lime green
three on the tree yeah
oh
and it was perfect
and um i got come wheeling up and he had
about probably a million two in money
markets cash never invested a thing
because he's a child of the depression
right just just stacked cash that's all
he did and i knew he had money but i
know how much till he died but um
i roll up in that thing with my cool
suit with the little pocket thing in it
you know look like ken coleman right yep
and um man i i i come rolling out of
that jaguar and he comes out and he
looks like what is that so it's a jaguar
and he goes what in the world
i said well it's a european vehicle
it'll
it's it's kind of fancy and he goes oh
it looks like it he goes what that thing
cost i told him he goes he whistled he
said
that's dumber than a rock
and i said
what do you mean you assaulted me i
thought i was cool i was there for my
grandpa to brag on me and he that's
dumber than a rock and i said what do
you mean he goes well you take that
amount of money and you put it in a
savings account you know how much you'll
be in there in 10 years and i said how
much he told me just
ran that calculator right
and i said um he said you know what that
car's gonna be worth in 10 years i said
well it holds its value he said no it
doesn't
that's that's a lot of people tell
themselves to buy crap like this
ah so mad i was mad for six weeks yeah i
mean i wasn't just mad for six minutes i
just left i mean i wasn't mad at him i
was just mad because he was right he's
right that's right you know and it
didn't you know it just had boiled me
boiled me because i was there i had a
whole different image a whole different
thing set up and of course i had
borrowed every dime i didn't a hundred
percent financed yeah you know and uh uh
man but you know that's one of those
lessons you just don't you don't get to
quote drive away from you know
smart people put the money in things
that go up in value dumb people put
money and things go down in value and
you need to buy some things that are
nice of course that have wheels i've got
nice cars but but they're a small
percentage of my net worth and of my
income i and i identify with this young
man because
it's a truck we're a couple of months
out from me finally replacing my old
truck when you needed to your old truck
was a piece of crap it's not your barrel
i still got it i got a couple more
months i'm not there yet look at you
kicking me while i'm down
but i also well the covered wagon jokes
gonna come back to haunt you
uh but hey i i understand i'm a couple
months out and i understand like i'll
just pull up i was just looking at
websites before the show started and
thought i bet i could i could pull the
trigger on the nope just follow the plan
man just follow the plan
take a breath calm down you're 20. wait
three more months it's time you're gonna
be married in 16 days
good idea to start marriage with her
being right yes
yes so because it will end with her
being right good idea that's good you
might as well start that way because
it's working it's going in yeah i mean
yeah i get i get man i get it man you
want a new truck you need a truck it's
all good all joking about wives and
stuff aside but here's the thing
who can find a virtuous wife the proverb
says
for her worth is far above rubies the
heart of her husband safely trusts her
and he will have no lack of gain
now his wife is not a nag she's not a
jerk his wife to be she just has wisdom
she's wise yeah and she just said this
isn't smart yep and he's like me he's
that little boy on the cereal aisle but
i want one i want one
and uh then he called this show and we
said no she's right my brother no